Tippie the Humboldt a penguin was
transferred to a center which is
specially equipped for his condition and
earlier we spoke to a penguin curator
who gave us a rundown of the facilities
that are on offer for dippy dippy is an
arthritic penguin he's about 20 years
old and he's had this after Isis for a
few years in his previous home so he's
come over here to stay with us he's on a
slightly different treatment regime to
the rest of our other Birds
he has x-rays regularly and we're under
quite close contact with our vets so
we'll be able to maintain his condition
and make sure that he's dealing with it
day to day we used to have an arthritic
penguin that came to live with us when
our enclosure first opened in 2009
called Lola and when we knew we're
getting her with her arthritis we have
this ramp specially built normally the
Penguins are incredibly good jumpers and
climbers and we encourage that from them
it's really good to keep their joints
nice and supple and keep them nice and
energetic but because you have bad days
and good days with arthritis we've had
this ramp specially built
so if nippy wants to just climb out of
there rather than climb out on the side
there then you can just literally walk
up the side there we have our incredibly
stringent and strict guidelines that we
have to work to call the zoo licensed in
act we have to work to that lots of
other wildlife parks have to work to
that and it just makes it quite tricky
for the smaller organizations to to stay
open but it means that we're all by
coming under this Welfare Act we're all
having a high degree of welfare for our
animals so they're getting all the care
they need and we were encouraging lots
of research and it really helped them
with the conservation of animals like
this you know children will never get to
see these in the wild so it's really
important they come and see them here
and after we find it people can actually
see animals then it gives them a lot
more of an affinity for them and
hopefully they'll start to think about
things like reduce and recycle in and
all sorts of other environmental factors
that affect first like these having
birds like dippy and having one of our
other artistic where's Lola it's really
important that our vets get to know as
much information as we can so if we ever
get birth like this is the future or any
of our other sea life centres do we know
what certain treatments work if they
respond to certain things and a lot
better care how we can give these guys